[Music]
okay Joe because you love love love
giving illegal advice I have another
question okay you're gonna say giving
head but go ahead so you do love giving
head oh yeah two chicks yeah I know that
cuz we're live shows thank God I was
there alright so this question here says
my husband and I have been married for
15 years and we have two elementary age
kids a few months ago I discovered by
accident that my spouse had been out of
work had long been out of work and had
hidden this from me including lying when
I asked specific questions she had
secretly opened multiple credit cards
parenthesis bills only came to his email
and incurred over $100,000 in debt Oh
it's unclear where the money went I'm
the primary breadwinner and with a great
deal of help and sacrifice we have begun
financial recovery but my kids know
something was wrong I had to cancel
almost all of their activities and some
everyday things like cable and it was
such an go for a while if they could
remain in their school and whatever we
could stay in our house this was all a
total shock my husband often prioritized
his own activities and interests and let
me handle everything with the children
but I knew he loved the kids it is
shocking to me that he really plays with
them they're shocking TV night he was so
cavalier with their lives and future let
alone mine I want a divorce
we remained in house as I've tried as I
tried to regroup financially but I feel
more secure now plus there's a there are
signs he's falling back into his old
habit I've seen a lawyer so I know what
to expect but how do I explain this to
my kids before this we got along well
spent time together did not fight in
front of them ministered and assured
them we would never get a divorce it's a
lie to say dad I love daddy but we can't
live together we can technically live
together and I stopped loving him once
he betrayed me but I can't tell
elementary aged kids that their father
committed near unbelievable financial
infidelity will you see your kids down
any like son daughter your daddy
unfortunately likes to buy diamonds
like what the [ __ ] me by this hot
$100,000 I have no idea how he spent
that much money but that new speed boat
in the driveway looks great so that's
what I'm saying like whatever you bought
it had to be small enough for he she
didn't know he bought it what the [ __ ]
is he buy and all and why doesn't she
like checked because right you can you
can find out like yeah like if she can
be like if you want us to stay together
let me see what you bought like she's
she sounds like she's still in the dark
even though she's trying to help him get
over this she meant to her investigative
work was it special massages yeah you
think he's playing runescape [ __ ]
games he's online games where you can
spend real money on it yeah you think
this cat's like buying all kinds of
[ __ ] horse armor
[Laughter]
my spouse and does not want a divorce
but living with someone I trust because
he can't be support himself and ruin my
children stability out of here and
selfishness is also agonizing how do I
negotiate this nightmare in a way that's
least awful for my kids
please don't suggest counselling I can't
afford neither the money nor the time
least awful for me I would [ __ ] say
your dad is a selfish con that's [ __ ]
up for the kids oh I always find the
easiest way to break news to kids is to
start with the puppet show
right and then we glue some buttons
choose the eyes and the nose are the
ugliest and we'll call this one daddy
let me play a little puppet show and
then Oh mommy doesn't like daddy more do
you want to burn this sock and then
you've been shot okay so what's
happening in real life or do you start
with the good news right
the good news son is that dad has a
really tricked-out
runescape character that's the good news
the bad news is that yeah we're getting
yours because Dylan elementary right
yeah so they're at the stage where you
can [ __ ] lie and create a fantasy
fruit you tell them send happy yeah
works as a special like special person
for the government daddy can't be with
us right now cuz he's doing something
very very important and with all world
saving the world what agency you're in
elementary school the BIA
what's the BIA I never it's confidential
yeah that's how secret it is it's so
secret that the world doesn't know and
you can't say anything my friend Robbie
says you're full of [ __ ] he says there
is no BIA i'ma call up Robbie's family
you [ __ ] keep this lie real
[ __ ] I can hear you that's how
that goes down I was a kid once
yeah well depends on what age in
elementary right you just you [ __ ]
tell them that this fool is part warlock
or some [ __ ] daddy is yeah you tell him
that daddy's a vampire and he got the he
got the vampire board and we can't have
him around us any more for your safety
it also depends on how much how much
honor the dad has left in him if well he
doesn't want the divorce he might not
even do this but if he has a little bit
find a job no tell the dad did that
breaks it to him oh the dad why is it
hurt the dad gets on his hands and knees
and apologize to the kids and how he
[ __ ] the whole family up and it should
come from him if he [ __ ] up yeah
versus making the mom be the bad person
it's like the mom is trying to hold the
family together that's true cuz my dad
wrote me a letter and my mom didn't have
to tell me [ __ ] he's probably trying to
use that as like a leverage point though
you know he just stay together he's like
oh I don't want a divorce if you want a
divorce you tell the kid his actions the
fact that he did all of that to lead to
this divorce already says where his
mentality is like there's no way he's
mature enough to do that well who knows
maybe he had $100,000 in crypto and he's
like you guys 2020 is the [ __ ] boy
year I could relate to that one right
a hundred thousand right twenty twenties
the [ __ ] yeah right and then it
didn't happen but all he needed was five
more years
yeah he just needed five four years but
then she's like I'm gone he goes honey
you don't understand it's gonna happen
maybe he's like you know I don't get it
your mom's really money obsessed the
kids I'm like damn so the advice that
was that was given in this advice column
I'm not gonna read it cuz really long
but pretty much they were saying like
you know it's really admirable you're
trying to protect your kids and also
like the your children's image of their
father and you know at this point in
time it's okay to kind of like skew the
truth a little bit
that's what I'm saying but not bad just
do it like hard like like hard like your
dad actually is a alien and we can't
have him here you really deal with this
well you're you you told your your kid
that your dad is a vampire alien and you
had to go I would let them watch all of
men and black from the very beginning
okay every day so they get it sayin
after we're done do we go alright so
your dad is many black but only you can
find out yeah and then the husband
doesn't want the divorce so the least he
can [ __ ] do is play along with however
they decide to tell the children so they
come at them like a united front so I'll
be like with dignity [ __ ] I'm
painting you in a good light you better
pretend that your men in black so you
better put on a black suit [ __ ]
with dignity with dignity you want that
[ __ ] flash yeah and you gotta wipe out
the kids memory man
suppose you gotta go up a bit like son
sons or daughters or whatever do I could
use this on you but I want you to
remember me so [ __ ] yeah dude I feel
like that light would last like months
double would adapt the men in black huh
what if it lasts for years like how
[ __ ] up are these gives me how long
did sound
last for I Isaac how long did he last
Elementary School no chance yeah yeah
really kids are telling you you're full
of [ __ ] if you say anything even true
things I said that my dad was a business
manager and they're like that's [ __ ]
dressed like that oh yeah I was
desperate I was very dapper actually my
mom did dress me like a young
businessman for some reason cuz my dad
used to just like that and so she just
bought like smaller clothes that my dad
had no taste what [ __ ] nas wait on the
kids but but that was my only defense
yeah my mouth so they could punch your
nuts there you go mmm dude I so I
recently got in big trouble with Nicki
big trouble not kidding either Oh weird
so we even play an animal crossing set
up well okay first of all if you eat
fruit in this game and you and you hit a
rock with anything
it breaks the rock okay so the idea is
you're not supposed to eat fruit you're
supposed to hit the rock a bunch of
times and then you can mine those rocks
every day and sometimes you get coins
sometimes you get clay sometimes you get
iron oh it's not like minecraft it
sounds like my kind of games fun okay so
I'm walking around the island I had just
eaten fruit to move some trees I didn't
remember my own strength and I started
to hit rocks and I'm like oh [ __ ] I
broke it all right oh [ __ ] oh that sucks
and then I'm walking around the island
and I do it again I think wait how am I
not out of fruit this sucks and I don't
know how to check my fruit meter or
whatever
what fruit did you eat I ain't a melon
Wow a 2 by 3 melons apparently so I
broke all the rocks on the island oh my
god takes a whole day for the take the
whole day to get one rock back so but I
didn't know is that there was an area
worth a bunch of walls around it where I
had broke a rock what I didn't know is
that Nicki had built a Zen garden around
this rock no and she thought it was
super sick that the rock was in the dead
center middle of it oh you can't you
can't move rocks either you can so like
there's no way
will ever appear in that garden ever
again
what she felt was a beautiful and
elaborate Zen garden iced I was a couple
walls around rock
why couldn't you bring your own island
you can't have your own Island who
[ __ ] intend Oh makes you live on the
on the same island as your the same
switch yes so I that's why he never
plays like it anymore most care you've
been banned I was the next morning I
wake up and I'm like and I'm like you
know good morning baby and all the [ __ ]
and she was like [ __ ] pissed at you
[ __ ] you destroyed my Zen garden I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
I didn't destroy anything I put
everything back especially because I
accidentally picked up a couple of walls
around the town and I had to put him
back because you can actually pick up
things a lot but I put him right back
where they were I didn't know that I had
[ __ ] up her whole Zen garden and she
was very pissed but here's the thing you
[ __ ] up Steve as a mature adult man I
can own this [ __ ] and realize where I
[ __ ] up right so what is really going
on here what's this really about it just
built a sandcastle and you kicked it
exactly and I didn't know I kicked it I
didn't want to do it but what it's about
is that she finally felt like she had
control over something that was hers and
I came in and I and I destroyed it
whether accidentally or not and so it's
just like when I was a kid and I my
little brother [ __ ] my toys or some
[ __ ] now man you [ __ ] my toy up [ __ ]
you like it's that same feeling of like
I can't control my own environment what
do I have control over so that's really
what the arguments about right and I can
so I can well restrain it Steve I can
own that [ __ ] and not make fun of her
because she got mad at me about a video
game which is what some people would do
and mistakenly we had sex
[Applause]
No yeah you guys should go in the game
and [ __ ] [ __ ] each other the game like
that black mirror episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]